à plusieurs moments dans des dispositifs
que j'avais mis en place j'étais très en
colère contre lui il le savait et je lui
dis bah écoute oui j'accepte ton pardon
mais est-ce que tu pourrais aller plus
loin je lui dis est-ce que par exemple
tu pourrais demander pardon à tous les
gens qui se sentent offensés parce que
tu as fait et dit notamment dans la
communauté juive il me dit Francis c'est
mon vœu le plus cher mais je n'arrive
pas à trouver quelqu'un qui accepte de
recevoir mon pardon et je lui ai dit tu
ne connais pas cette communauté moi je
la connais bien je l'aime profondément
et il y a dans cette communauté des gens
qui bien sûr ne sont pas d'accord pour
recevoir ton pardon mais il y en a
beaucoup que tu as offensé qui sont très
touchés par ton par ton message de ta
demande de pardon parce qu'en plus tu
leur asnuies à deux de manière tu
l'auras nu parce que tu les as offensés
mais surtout tu leur ennuies parce que
tu les as privé de leur comique préféré
parce que il y a beaucoup de gens qui
dans la communauté juive qui adoraient
Dieudonné et puis et puis qui quand il a
commencé à dire ces choses-là ben on
était aussi privés de leur comique